Lance pleasure to meet you pleasure to
meet you too very happy to be here what
are you all about ince yourself oh yeah
uh well my name is Lance um I'm doing my
PhD with k friston um my background is
in is in mathematics uh so I did pure
mathematics for a while and uh I started
thinking about what I wanted to do with
my life it was all very abstract and I
was just really interested in the brain
like um a lot of people in my family
have uh psychiatric diseases so I guess
that was a clear
motivation and um I was also super
interested in artificial intelligence I
started thinking about all of the
technologies that would transform
society and I had this moment where you
know I had to make a decision what what
am I going to spend my life doing and uh
obviously I wanted to have an impact and
out of All Tech all emerging
Technologies I mean artificial
intelligence seemed the thing that
really like got to me and it seemed the
thing that had that would have a most
the most profound imp impact on society
as a whole uh so I decided to go in
there and um I quickly realized that a
lot of what was um a lot of what people
were doing at the time was not
principled it was mostly based on deep
learning and I was really disenchanted
with this approach I guess it was really
like this um pure mathematicians
attitude to things where you want to
have like proofs you want to have
theorems you want to have guarantees you
want to really understand what the
system's doing
and you want to I guess I wanted to
understand what intelligence was all
about uh and deep learning I mean to
some extent they can do smart things but
they really don't tell you anything
about the nature of intelligence so I
decided to go into Neuroscience as well
for that other reason um and so I
started hearing about the free engineer
principal who was a friend at the time
who told me about oh there's this
amazing paper about uh the free energy
principle is it a unified brain Theory
so I read that I didn't understand it at
all uh but it just seemed really
exciting uh so I decided to you know get
into that space I started working with
Carl friston I did my thesis with him
and um basically I realized that the
free principle had a lot of potential or
at least it seemed like it had but there
was no underlying mathematical Theory
supporting the principle so it's like we
make this claim that all intelligent
agents minimize free energy and they do
that for perception action decision-
making and whatnot but we actually so we
claim that we have this principle but we
actually don't have you know um rock
solid reasons to believe that this is
true uh so basically my thesis has been
about laying out those mathematical
foundations that would justify why the
principle is right and I'm super happy
to say that now uh or at least in like a
couple months we'll have like papers out
that will you know show show the rock
solid foundation that would be able to
convince any mathematician or physicist
that's interested in the subject of like
if you have a brain or if you have an
intelligent agent that's out there it
has to comply with the free engine
principle this is just how things work
how physics work and you know this lays
a rock solid foundation for principled
AI I think in the many years to come and
maybe this is the end goal Theory we
we'll see yeah I mean that there's three
interesting things to touch on I mean um
we should discuss what you think
intelligence is but um you were saying
that there's that you know we need a
mathematical foundation for the why
question and also for the necessity
question so why don't we start with that
so what work have you done to kind of
demonstrate the the why the free energy
principle is true well um so you have to
take a very you have to start from the
basics and when I say Basics like from
basic physics um of what it is to be an
agent what it is to interact with the
world and I would say the fundamental
tenet or the fundamental assumption that
underlies the free energy principle is
that any agent uh has a boundary with
its environment and it's going to
exchange information through that
boundary and moreover uh the boundary
that you and I have with uh our
environment is comprised of sensory
States and active States and so you have
this kind of like cybernetic Loop uh
this flow of information for like uh the
environment influences your sensory
States your vision and whatnot sensory
States influences the brain the brain
influences the active States you're
going to do movement uh for example and
act on the
environment and so if you just start
with those uh fundamental assumptions
and you say well um I mean there is some
Dynamics I mean the world evolves you as
a person evolv and there is this
interaction and you take this uh very
general formul of dynamics that
underlies all of physics theories which
is based on stochastic differential
equations M if you say that the world
and the agent are governed by a
stochastic differential equation and
this is in itself not really an
assumption because statistical physics
quantum mechanics they're all based on
stochastic differential equations if you
just start with that you uh you just do
a bunch of derivations and you can show
that um the internal States the brain
minimize free energy and in so doing
they infer uh what's going on in the
environment based on the observations
that you have so it's basically just a
theorem okay but if I understand
correctly you're saying given some
assumptions and there are quite a few
assumptions so the the Primacy of an
agent and the um this concept of a
cybernetic um agent Loop where we pass
information around in a multi-agent
system and and then you're kind of
saying okay well we're using similar
models to what we do in physics so like
stochastic differential equations and we
can then look at um how the Dynamics
change over time and you know things
like the repartitioning of of entropy
and so on and you're kind of saying okay
well so I'm I'm I'm looking at that
process now and based on that process in
many different environments that's
answering the question of why the free
energy principle is true yeah but you
make it sound a lot more complicated
than it is I think um so you're just
saying there has to be a dynamic that
governs the world and we're just going
to take the most General model of
dynamic that exists which is stochastic
differential equations in this
assumption is not an assumption because
all of physics is based on stochastic
differential equations and so if you if
we want to describe the world if we want
to have a a theory of the brain which is
part of the physical world then we
should be starting with that and then
the other assumption is the notion of a
boundary now uh the boundary uh is I
mean is allowed to interact freely with
the environment and with the the brain
uh but then you just say there is a part
of the boundary that need not interact
with the brain like need not influence
the brain directly this would be the
active States and there there is a part
of the boundary that need not directly
influence the external States uh the
environment and those would be the
sensory States so you basically just
have this boundary assumption and then
the freand principle follows and I would
say all the rest is just like Co
cosmetic stuff uh but which is basically
very natural when you're a physicist
interesting I mean a couple of things on
there I mean first of all I I love the
idea of there being a physics of
intelligence and that's because yeah
it's AES I philosophically believe that
intelligence is a material physical
thing you know I don't think it's like a
purely abstract virtual thing so I'm on
board with that but um I I guess like
would you accept that it might just be a
lens you know like any other physical
Theory it's like an intelligible
abstract lens that seems to give a lot
of predictive power but might not
represent the real thing yeah it's a
it's a very interesting you say that so
I mean for sure it is a lens because
we're using the lens of physics and
Mathematics to express things um and so
we're basically deriving equations now
um but then again the beauty of
mathematics and physics is that you have
equations that really represent or that
we believe really represent something
that's out there um now I I believe the
free energy principle can be
considerably
refined uh at the moment for
example I mean the fact that we have
just very few assumptions on the theory
means that the free energy principle
just applies to Stones it applies to
birds it applies to any kinds of animals
it applies to cells and viruses and it's
cool I mean we get this um really uh
sparse and general description of what
intelligence is but then you can also
argue like if this description of
intelligence can be applied to Stones is
that really so useful in and of
itself um so it is useful because we can
use these equations to create artificial
intelligence but uh as we move forward
we want to refine the free energy
principle to have a description that
applies exclusively to brains and not to
uh other animals that we think are less
intelligent and as we move towards this
more uh refined description then we get
more powerful algorithms that create um
more sophisticated forms of artificial
intelligence yeah I mean I think it is
useful in in so many ways because we
anthropomorphize intelligence so it's
the least anthropomorphic definition of
intelligence there is actually out of
all of them and and I study all of them
and um it also allows an externalist
view of cognition which I'm very big
well it's it's an integrated view so you
you can have a combination of Minds
which have representations about the
world around them but also you know like
a kind of of um distributed composition
of Minds that act as a single mind
depending on some abstract boundary yeah
and and also this material view of of
intelligence which I think is very very
powerful so I think it's very very
instructive to think about intelligence
in this way but of course it's similar
to how biologists think of intelligence
it's not something that really makes
sense to a lot of people because you're
just thinking about it almost as a form
of Dynamics in in a physical system
rather than something we would
recognize yeah that's true um but I
would say if you want to express
intelligence in um in mathematics and
physics in the end it will it will have
to be Dynamics uh because things happen
in time and as you're making decisions
you're doing perception it's going to
take time um the language of Dynamics is
what underlies uh all of our physical
descriptions of things and I would say
and you were saying how biologists think
about intelligence and it's maybe a less
of a t ible understanding and that's all
right but I would say like a lot of
scientific progress is just like it
paves way for physical and mathematical
theories at the end of the day once our
comprehension has matured at least
that's my point of view and what's
really exciting with um uh intelligence
and and Neuroscience at this particular
point in time is that we're starting to
be able to have these physical and uh
mathematical overarching theories for
what the brain is doing and there's
still a lot of work to be done in terms
of refining the free energy principle
like I would say we are at the level of
intelligence 1.0 in terms of the free
engery principle we have the first
iterations of the free energy principle
that are rock solid all the this
description of intelligence and
cognition that applies to a wide number
of organisms uh that's now Rock Solid
but now we need to refine and move to
intelligence 2.0 3.0 and so on uh so
it's going to take a long time but this
this is in my opinion um a very
important moment in science in that
we're starting to have physics and
Mathematics actually be able to descri
describe the brain in a very profound
way even though it's still very coar
grained the description that we have in
terms of the 300 principle and now we
can have um physicists and
mathematicians you know really talk
about the brain and collaborate with
neuroscientists and work towards what
could be uh you know an ultimate theory
of the brain that's specific to the
brain much like you have um an ultimate
theory of the movement of planets with
general relativity and so on yeah this
makes a lot of sense to me and it's
biologically plausible in a way that
current neural networks are not yeah and
um I was just saying earlier in one of
my other interviews that um there are
some relations to artificial life you
know like cellular autometer but this is
somewhere in the middle because we're
explicitly modeling agents and the
Agents have you know selfhood and they
can model other other agents and they
can have a lot of the kind of dynamics
that you have in in artificial life but
we can we can steer them but
steerability is is this trajectory you
know on on these different levels of
implementation so artificial life is not
very steerable the free energy principle
is slightly more steerable and neuron
networks is very steerable and I think
we're kind of going for this middle way
where we are using active inference and
we might use some components of other
models so we might use um let's say
encoders like Transformers encoders or
we might um endow um certain cognitive
Primitives into the models we were
talking about cognitive Primitives last
night and we're going to end up with
some kind of hybrid which uses all of
these different approaches we're talking
about and we think that something very
intelligent could emerge from that far
beyond which is possible with neural
networks yeah I mean this this is very
interesting um so I mean you've
highlighted kind of like three
converging themes I would say there's
the free energy principle which gives us
PR a principle and some equations to
implement to have intelligent Behavior
havior then the other one is core
knowledge like what is kind of your
starting point or your prior
understanding of the world um that is
potentially shared by you know infants
and that leads to a more uh humanlike
form of intelligence and understanding
and then there's the third pillar which
is taking techniques from engineering
and deep learning that are out there and
that work very well for a number of
things to scale up those models based on
the free engine principle and it's true
that for the past few years
in our community we see like closer and
closer inter integration and convergence
between free energy principle uh active
inference uh principled
algorithms uh that unfortunately at the
moment do not do not scale as much as we
would like them to and then we take uh
all of these techniques from AI like uh
deep learning reinforcement learning
ways to scale those reinforcement
learning algorithms and we combine them
together to have principled and scalable
algorithms I would say though this is
very exciting but I would say though
this is just a stepping stone because we
haven't yet found uh proper principled
ways to scale those active inference
algorithms um and in my opinion the key
to do that uh well there's actually two
keys one is structure learning um so the
thing that we are not currently able to
do in active inference is to learn a
model of the world in a scalable way and
by that I mean like if you have a robot
be in an environment that he has no idea
about like how is the robot going to
construct a model of that environment
the fact that I'm sitting on a chair and
there's other chairs around me and that
if I you know walk in a certain
direction I'll end up bumping into a
chair and so on this is something that
infants do extremely well just by
exploring their
environment um and you know learning by
try and error and constructing these Mo
this like very rich model and detailed
description of the world as time goes on
and this is something that we do not
know how to do right now so I would say
this is like the major technological
leap and
conceptual um theoretical leap that we
need to do in the next couple of years
uh so that's one thing the structure
learning the other thing is the core
knowledge yeah so as we you know as we
evolve and we want to build robots and
AI systems that interact with us we want
them to share uh similar or ideally the
same representations of the world and
understanding of the world that we have
yeah um so that's one thing and the
other thing is that if you want to do
structur learning you want to you know
create this model of the world if you
actually want to instantiate that uh
mathematically or in code it just turns
out to be like a very hard optimization
problem like it's like um I'm in this
room and there's
all these possible models of the world
that I could use to describe this room
um
99.99999% of them are just going to be
rubbish they're not going to describe
chairs there's not going to describe
ceiling and so on they're not even going
to correspond to any type of
naturalistic
environment um so you just want to
exclude that and search that space of
world models until you converge to a
world model that actually does a good
job of explaining your environment this
is an extremely hard optimization
problem and the reason why we're not
able to do structur learning just yet
and it's not just us but it's basically
everybody in the machine learning
community and I would say like so many
groups everywhere in so many different
communities and converging to that
ultimate problem of structure learning
from many different
directions um so we're not able to solve
that optimization problem and actually I
I believe the key to solving that
optimization problem and the structuring
structure learning problem at large core
knowledge is core knowledge AB
absolutely so core knowledge is just
like uh so this's this great paper by
elizabethy on on core knowledge this six
six systems of core knowledge that we
are born with yeah um so there's like um
innate core knowledge on objects in a
core knowledge on agents uh basic
mathematics there's a bunch of them and
so if we are able to reverse engineer
that core knowledge uh en code them as
priors in the in the active inflence
models that we have then this really
constrains uh the space of generative
models and World models that you would
want to use to represent the world yeah
so all this cor knowledge I mean it's
amazing because it's like things that
you don't even think about like for
example object permanence object
permanence like of course objects are
permanent and we never think about it
because it's so obvious but now if
you're able to you know take that thing
and encode it as a prior or as a
constraint on your search for World
models then it really decreases the
complexity of the of the search problem
it really decreases the size of the size
of the space of world models that you
want to search and so I guess with that
you this would be the way of solving
structure learning in the long term I I
agree it'll it'll help a hell of a lot
and I I love um spell Key's paper and
you know manifestly we know this is the
way the human brain works for example
with the grid and play cells you know we
have we have spatial priors and even the
concept of an agent is a spell key prior
and the agent is foundational to the
free energy principes so I mean that
that does give me um pause and and um
reason to think that that it is a
fundamental thing and that's why it's in
there but um as you know there are an
infinite number of um structured
representations you know models for the
environment that we're in and many of
them need to be significantly more
Nuance than the spelly prior so then
like we've already had this tradition in
machine learning with the B expence
tradeoff of producing inductive priors
that do things like symmetries and God
knows what else and um you know
receptive fields for example and um rich
rich Sutton came along and he wrote this
essay called The Bitter lesson and he
basically said that you know all you
need is computation any attempt to imbue
symmetries and priers and human
knowledge into systems will inevitably
fail well reinforcement learning is not
doing terribly well at the moment and
you look at things like chat GPT because
in the olden days we used to do expert
systems and they were brittle and then
you know we had the rich Saturn phase of
doing reinforcement learning you know
just from machine learning prior and now
we're kind of back to chat GPT where
it's all human encoded knowledge again
so like you know what where do you fall
on that well it's it's really
interesting and and and I just want to
like concur with you know those I mean
there's a lot of divisive opinions right
now and I was at this um reinforcement
learning and decision- making conference
last year and it was really interesting
because this conference uh so there was
Richard Sutton there are also core
knowledge folks like Josh tenenbom who
you know spend their life reverse
engineering core knowledge so there was
all this crowd from Deep Mind and all
the like hardcore RL people like Andrew
Barto Richard Sutton and then there were
a bunch of neuroscientists very famous
Ones Josh tenam uh Peter Diane and so on
and there were basically two different
opinions two different camps uh there
were the reinforcement learning people
and I think that was uh in particular
like deep mind the Deep Mind people
really thought in this way of like you
just need compute power yeah and and
reward reward is enough yeah exactly the
reward is enough people you just need
compute power and you know if you have
enough compute power you can train your
agent for God knows how how long and he
will end up learning the core knowledge
that he needs I guess for to Opera in
its environment and much more and then
there there are the other people like
Josh tenam who went to create like
humanlike artificial
intelligence and humanlike Sample
efficiency M um and they're very
interested I mean they think coronal is
a way to go and I really agree with that
but I would think um actually the reason
why there there is this divide is that
the goals are different um people like
Richard Sutton they want to they do not
want to be constrained by humanlike
artificial intelligence and the
representations that we have they want
to you know just create intelligence and
see what emerges and for example when we
think about you know uh the Go I mean
Alpha go and all of these like programs
for playing Go and chess they come up
with like really new alien creative ways
to to you know selfo and chess ways that
probably you could not have come up with
if you had like humanlike AI that had
our core knowledge could I touch on that
though you're absolutely right so that
that is the argument so when when you
train and early versions of um you know
their go system did train on on Human
episodes and that weirdly converged it
hit it hit an upper limit of skill so
when they did the selfplay it the skill
ceiling was significantly higher which
was fascinating yeah but it's not quite
as simple as that though is it so and
and and by the way it still converged
but much higher but there was a kind of
structure to it so we all know that the
that the the skill space is
exponentially large like all of the
computation in the universe wouldn't let
you saturate that space so if you think
about it there's there's this very
structured space that alphao has learned
there's a kind of manifold and I I call
it the Swiss cheese problem which is
that there're all of these holes in the
Swiss cheese so like if you
adversarially you know like this has
been discovered recently that humans can
like make some weird moves even during
the game that move 47 on Alpha goett
made a train of crazy moves it was just
suddenly playing like a child it wasn't
playing like a super intelligent machine
anymore so it's like it's a bit of an
illusion it's far more poal listic than
than we think it is
that's that's really interesting I mean
the the way I think about it I always
come back to like this intuition of like
the no free lunch theorems yeah exactly
um and I feel that the more amount of
core knowledge and priors that you're
going to give your system whatever that
is the faster uh you're going to learn
but the more constrained you're going to
be in the solution that you end up with
um and I would say the the
neuroscientists and cognitive scientists
they they want to have this human core
knowledge because they want to
understand our brain they're not so
interested in artificial intelligence
they want to reproduce exactly what our
brain is and so they want to converge on
the solution that us as humans has have
con have converged at in terms of
intelligence um on the other hand the
people doing hardcore artificial
intelligence they don't care so much
about the human brain and they just want
to see how intelligence can be uh can we
really get um we have this enormous
advantage of like we're not constrained
by the resources uh that our bodies have
we have immense amounts of computation
so let's just harness that uh put less
core knowledge even maybe no core
knowledge at all and then we're going to
you know let the agent train for a very
long time and conversion to a much
smarter agent I would say the only
drawback is once you have that type of
agent that does not necessarily share um
our representations then it becomes very
hard to
communicate that's very true and I would
also say like the benchmarks are
completely broken so I mean recently
there are examples of gp4 supposedly
playing an ELO of of 1800 and that's
that's just right you know
because you can't take this is a problem
all the time that people say um you know
humans that can do a can do B therefore
if a Transformer can do a it should do B
which is like extrapolating on the human
manifold of intelligence in the domain
of machines same thing with benchmarks
you can't just take the Benchmark of or
like you know the whole point of skill
is you're talking about extrapolation
between like other humans in the same
population so like talking about human
elos in respect of GPT just doesn't
really tell you anything and even with
the self-play thing like the only reason
why those those holes in the Swiss
chiefs were not found during selfplay is
because like for whatever reason their
self-play exploration policy wasn't
exploring those parts of the search
space so the whole that's the thing I
think people just don't understand just
how ridiculous and brittle these
benchmarks are there are no systematic
like evaluations of any of this stuff
yeah I mean app and oranges at the end
of the day I think as long as you don't
have human like core knowledge then
you're comparing apples and oranges and
I think it just comes back to the fact
that back in the day I mean beating the
world champion at chess was considered a
huge feat of artificial intelligence now
no one thinks about it because it's
obvious that machines play better at
chess than us but we still think that
machines are overall very dumb and I
just like the fact is machines are just
very good at doing things that we're not
good at and vice versa yeah was it
Minsky I can't remember who said oh you
know when when we um solved chess then
we would have solved artificial
intelligence but this is the amazing
thing there were all of these uncanny
valleys now things that were
unimaginable to us 5 years ago and now
we can actually see what's it like to
have a lifelike Avatar and what's it
like to have a chatbot that is
indistinguishable from a human and yeah
we trans transgress the Youngy Valley
but we're we're also kind of like the
fog of war is Lifting and this you know
the mordu effect the mordu effect which
is that a chorus of people say well
that's not really intelligence because
once actually see it it doesn't seem
like intelligence anymore but we are we
are feeling out the structure and space
of of what it is to be intelligent which
is quite interesting yeah yeah
definitely I mean I think we've just
realized that the human brain is not
very good at doing computation in the
sense of like uh just thinking many
times uh many steps ahead for chess or
go I mean we're very bad at dealing with
this combinator explosion of of moves
and I would say we're also to a certain
extent bad at doing mathematics like
that's maybe not what what our you know
what our genes um enable us to do the
best on the other hand we're excellent
at pattern recognition at Thinking Fast
uh using a very low amount of energy and
for example recognizing faces uh but
these are all things are enabled by core
knowledge I mean we have all these like
dedicated systems for emotion
recognition face recognition and so on
that just enable us to operate as social
uh animals in our community
and this has just evolved for a very
long time I mean throughout Evolution um
and I think I mean now that you know uh
playing go is not a problem for machines
and you know playing Starcraft and
whatever is not a problem we're just
realizing okay well there are still
these things that we can do much better
than machines and it seems like we're
we're so good at this because we're so
specialized at this and the only way
maybe to get that at least like the most
promising way to get it uh you know in
the next few years is to reverse
engineer core knowledge I would say it's
definitely not the only way to go but it
seems very promising yeah no I agree and
I'm a huge fan of of tanan B and yeah I
loved his dream code of paper I've been
trying to get him on the podcast he's a
tough nut to crack actually all right
but um yeah no completely on board with
that and and also I mean I think like
the big elevator pitch for me is that um
you know all intelligence is specialized
and actually human intelligence is much
more specialized in brittle than people
think I mean I was thinking of a thought
experiment last night I mean if you
could have a perfect simulator of the
world and us and you placed yourself in
a in this room and then just like in The
Matrix you can just make the walls
disappear disappear and and now all of a
sudden you realize you're in The Ether
and there's just white everywhere and
you're not in the real world anymore and
how quickly would mode collapse happen
you know because you think you're so
flexible but you're now in this alien
world and all of a sudden like you just
go crazy you know like all of these
mental health problems um materialize
and like basically full mode collapse so
we just assume that we are so flexible
we could live anywhere we can do
anything and that's just not the case
you know like we anthropomorphize
everything and we delude ourselves and
that's the go that that's true that's
true and I would say I mean the free
principle gives you a very nice
perspective on this it's like as you get
older you get like more and more
specialized at whatever it is you do and
I just I don't just mean work but I mean
like uh being at ease in your
environment in the environment that you
surround with yourself with um so you
become like much more efficient but you
become much less adaptable yeah and
that's probably and on the other hand
when you're like a little kid you can
probably adapt much better to these type
of environments that you just mentioned
that that would be completely alien to
us uh because you just you're not so
constrained by um the your posteriors
which has become which have become very
sharp uh and you know adapted to a
particular type of environment and I
would say that's a weakness that we have
as humans like particularly in our age
in the sense that um I mean there is
this growing understanding that
technological progress is exponential I
would say maybe a noisy exponential and
um things are happening at a much much
faster pace and then there is this quote
that I absolutely love is that you know
um back in like two centuries ago a
problem for a person would be not being
able to read and write uh now the
equivalent in our Century would be not e
being able to continuously learn unlearn
and
relearn but uh what the freand principle
tells us is that once we get old enough
it becomes extremely hard to unlearn and
extremely hard to relearn and that's a
weakness that we have uh that makes us
that make that will make it possibly
harder and harder to adapt to this uh
growing pace of technological progress
and that's not a weakness that the
machines that we will create have
because we have this thing called Basin
model reduction of like pruning
connections in the in the model of the
world in the Gen model where it becomes
very easy for an agent to unlearn
something to be able to relearn
something yeah but I was thinking about
that you know we're talking about all of
these prior like the prior in the in the
natural world and I had actually thought
about that that's a very interesting one
that agents tend to become more
sclerotic it's a bit like the simulated
analing algorithm you know where like
you know at the beginning ping pong
balls going all over the place and then
over time as as as the temperature
decreases it makes smaller and smaller
yeah and um and I'm not sure whether it
would be because you were kind of saying
well it' be a good idea not to have that
prior in an agent I'm not so sure having
an exponential decay sorry you do get
that in in um like gradient
optimizations you have like weight Decay
over time so like over time the the
weight so it seems like a very natural
thing to do but there are so many
examples of of these PRI that we just
put into our models yeah well I think
it's a great thing to have but let's say
um let's say you're like 80 years old
and you move to a new country you take
on a new job it's it's going to be very
hard to adapt
uh when you have those very precise
priors um yeah it becomes a problem now
if you have a machine who's you know
been in a warehouse for a very long time
and you put it in the outside world to
interact with kids you can just have it
unlearn uh just by like modifying the
code and you will be able to relearn uh
how you know how to interact in this new
environment in a very very uh efficient
way yeah I know I was I was um chatting
about that earlier I almost prefer
um the idea of killing an agent rather
than kind of complexifying and adapting
but yeah like there is a fine line so
one one view is is having like continual
learning and and and adaptability and
another way is XM are going to swap out
swap out the agent you know so it
effectively dies and just put a new one
in there that's that's actually probably
an even uh faster solution yeah yeah
yeah yeah anyway I mean so to sum up a
little bit I mean there are three themes
that we've been talking about so first
of all like the the the the agents and
then secondly like um structure learning
and core knowledge
just touching on the agents thing just
just for a second I mean I'm a huge fan
of of multi-agent you any kind of agent
representation in in general and I guess
like could you tease apart how much of
the cash value is coming from the agent
um framework versus the active
inference what do you mean by cash value
well as in like there are many ways of
implementing an agent framework I mean
like I could I could Implement an agent
framework and I could solve like an atar
game and I could like create a policy
using um I don't know like quality
diversity or something like that so like
there's you get a lot just from having
the agent framework and what the agent
framework allows you to do is there's an
element of ensembling so like you know
being able to have like a population of
different types of model that learn
about the environment and like sort of
dynamically switching information
between them there's something quite
magical about agent even without the
free energy principle yeah
absolutely
um yeah I mean so so the question is
what does really active inflence bring
to the picture in practice when we when
we have engines interacting is yeah so
over and above like you know like
multi-agent reinforcement learning or or
any other multi-agent system like what
what is the magic of applying Fe yeah I
mean that's a great question and uh it's
an even better question in the sense
that most people in reinforcement
learning are just wondering you know why
why are we coming up with all these
things um and I would say I mean there
there's a few reasons the first one is
uh now we have a straight path from like
first principles math and physics to
application um so there there is some
theoretical Beauty to it but then when
it just comes to pragmatism uh active
inference it brings you a lot of
advantages in terms of uh safety and
explainability and I would say this is
like a very big problem that you know
people are contending with with deep
learning and reinforcement learning
overall
um and that's do you mean by virtue of
the fact that having specialized agents
is more intelligible or do you mean by
virtue of the fact that you can white
box the predictive model um I mean that
the the description of intelligence
given by the free energy principle and
active inference is extremely sparse and
simple it's just based on a gen model
and minimizing free energy which means
that when the agent makes a particular
decision it becomes very simple to
understand why it is that the agent did
this particular thing and so you can
always trace it back to either the free
energy minimization process or some
representation of the world in the agent
generative
model um so I think one of the biggest
contributions of active inference
practically is to unlocking uh safety
and explainability and so for instance
um I mean we all want self driving cars
right and and I would say I've been
reading about sell driving cars for a
very long time and I've wanted it to
happen it's just not happening because
we have these systems who maybe take
some particular decisions and we're not
able to trace back why they made this
particular
decision then it becomes too risky to
you know use RL to put in a self-driving
car or do other things like assisted
surgery the the stakes are just too high
and we place um we place a lot of value
in human life and it's just not going to
happen uh with active inference we're
going to be able to get there eventually
got to push back on that a tiny bit
though because it it sounds a little bit
you know like with a a cellular
autometer the underlying rules are very
simple but it gives rise to unimaginable
complexity so it sounds a little bit
like you're saying well with the free
energy principle we understand you know
why it acted the way it did but the
predictive model that it represents
is very very complex so we still don't
understand it yeah so so you could you
could have the problem of like you don't
understand the Gen of model but as we
move forward we're going towards more
and more explainable Gant of models so
we had we had this conversation before
of now we have like a Synergy between uh
mainstream machine learning and active
inference where we use components from
machine learning like we use deep
learning uh neuron Nets and we put them
in the generative models to make them
more expressive um I think that's a
problem I mean it gets us somewhere for
the time being but it's a problem
because as soon as you have neuron Nets
and you put them in the Gant models you
sacrifice explainability just because
you don't understand what the neuron
Nets are doing uh as we move forward the
things that we're working on right now
is to have genetic models that have no
neuron Nets and uh we're not just the
only group working on this there's also
at least the for example the Tenon B
group uh I think Josh Tenon B from the
last conversation I have with him he he
really not very not keen on having
neural networks do things and he wants
to move um to gentic models that are
just very interpretable and I would say
there's two reasons for that one of them
is explainability for all applications
this is really something we want to have
the other thing is for his particular
agenda of understanding the human mind
and cognition if you want to you know
have an agent that reproduces the human
cognition in in some way if you
implement this agentur neural networks
is not going to be able to tell you
anything scientific I know and this is
something that I worry might be a really
difficult thing to achieve because we
were talking about structural learning
you know so like maybe we could think of
structural learning as as a generative
model which you know actually produces
some intelligible structure about about
the current environment but let's talk
about dreamcoder which was Tannon B's
paper and he had this um this neuron
Network that would essentially dream and
learn to compose these primitive Library
modules that was in a different part of
the system and essentially you would get
these programs which were compositions
of like underlying functional Primitives
and then they would be recursively
recomposed and recomposed and then you
you run the model for you know several
um episodes and these programs which are
learned even though they're comprised of
Primitives which are understandable the
overall composition of the program is
now completely intelligible and I worry
that with any form of structural
learning that will always be the case
like we'll never understand it yeah uh
so I agree with you uh but I would say
we're pushing even further from from
that dreamcoder paper but just to step
back a little bit so uh from my latest
conversations with Josh tenal uh so he's
of course very exciting by very excited
by this dream coder work and of course I
can't speak for him but the impression
that I had is that he's more excited
about doing structured learning with um
basically you would have like a set of
building blocks like basic building
blocks um like Primitives and then you
would do Basin inference to do structure
learning so you would infer uh based on
those building blocks and basically the
space of all models that you could have
from those basic building blocks uh then
you do Bas and inference to you know
solve that search problem and infer the
right model to explain the world around
you now it all comes down to the
building blocks that you're using so you
mentioned probalistic programs this is
like a very interesting Avenue your
research and this is definitely
something that's pursued in the ten and
B lab the problem I guess with
probabilistic programs as you mentioned
is that they can get unworldly very
quickly I mean if you just have a bunch
of for loops and wall loops and you know
uh do just a bunch of things it could
practically do anything so it's very
expressive but it becomes very
complicated and very hard to understand
what the agent is doing yeah what we're
pushing forward in um with Kyle friston
and and colleagues at versus is the
factor graph approach where we do not
have ultimately we will not have any
deep neural networks and we'll just have
Factor graphs that explain the world now
the factor graphs they're amazing
because uh each factor just corresponds
to a representation of the world and
then the connections tells you okay this
this representation interacts with this
but more importantly it doesn't interact
with all of those other representations
in the GM model so now you can very see
very efficiently what the
representations of the agent are and how
these connect with each other and how
the flow of information in the agent's
brain goes about and so it becomes uh I
would say as easy as it could get to
understand uh why the agent did this
particular thing what was the agent
thinking at this particular moment in
time what was the message passing uh
between the agent neurons and the agent
factors that led to this particular
decision at least uh so this is what
we're pushing towards and I would say uh
when you have that then it becomes uh
the thing become becomes as explainable
as it could get yeah and I'm on board of
that so that I think there are ways to
structure you know to to um add
pressures to the structureal learning
process so that the um the priers which
are selected um mediate to things that
that we understand and and you know they
were already presses like parimon for
example which would be as simple as
possible but yeah that that makes a lot
of sense and the only reason I brought
that up is I mean I've played around
with France's Arc Challenge and he was
big on on the spelly prize and most of
the solutions for that challenge were
just kind of um searching over a DSL of
domain specific um you know operations
on this 2D grid and you know it's it's
an exponential search but when you look
at the the solutions you just end up
with this kind of brittle confection of
of programs and then um you kind of look
at it and you're thinking okay well
weirdly it works quite well but sure it
doesn't feel like it should work and the
the wind of the arc challenge actually
said you know I I don't feel like a
winner I don't feel like what I've
created here is any form of artificial
intelligence right and you know um
Minsky said you know that that we have a
Society of Mind we have many specialized
programs for doing very different things
and that seems that seems wrong but
again at the right level of abstraction
you know when we talk about these PRI
which should generalize in in in the
environment we're in it seems like the
right thing to do so it's just like
finding the right the right for sure
yeah I also want to add like um in terms
of explainability the free principle
says that the the best model to explain
the world around you to the structure
learning is the one that minimizes free
energy free energy can be decomposed
into accuracy minus complexity so as
you're optimizing free energy you're
getting sparer and least complex models
they need to be still very complex
because they need to represent the world
around us in an accurate way but out of
those models that do a good job of
explaining the world around us we're
going to select the the least complex
ones so we're going to prune as many
Connections in the factor graph as we
can which makes it more and more I mean
easier to understand what the agent is
doing I know and it's a it's a really
interesting thing because on the one
hand it's very principle just to have
this underlying free energy principle
you know the energy and the entropy and
but then when you link it to things like
the construction of of factor graphs
you're almost kind of cajoling something
which knows about energy and entropy you
know and and as a by product you might
want it to produce a certain type of
factor graph or if it's an agent you
might want it to maintain a certain
amount of Behavioral complexity or it
needs to it needs to maintain these
behaviors but have flexibility in these
behaviors and you might do that by
indirect you know like prodding the
boundary or kind like doing weird things
to it well yeah I mean maybe maybe you
would have to do that but I feel I mean
the the best model is always going to be
um in relation to the data that the
agent has gathered um so in principle
just by minimizing free energy you would
converge onto the right model but then I
think the question also comes down to
what is the model space uh that you are
exploring that you are allowing the
agent to explore and it then comes down
to the types of Primitives that you're
using and there's different schools of
thought right there's the factor graph
approach there's the Tenon B approach on
like a probabilistic programs one thing
um that really excites me from the Tenon
bound work um is that they've converged
to very similar models to the active
inflence Community but from a very very
different approach so we have this like
principle take on active inference from
like the freand principle and math and
physics which I would say is like a top-
down approach to artificial
intelligence uh this Tenon B Crow and
colleagues they've converged to very
similar models from a bottom up approach
of doing a lot of experimentation with
humans and feding models and they've
converged to like the expected free
energy like expected utility and
expected Information Gain as an
objective to make informed and uh useful
decisions um and they have all of these
things are just very close to what we're
doing and one paper that really excites
me from um the work that they did is on
a theory based reinforcement learning
where they had this agent which is
basically an active inference agent
although they don't call it that way uh
interact in an Atari like environment
and do structure learning and interact
with the environment using BAS expected
free energy and what they do is they um
they compare the learning uh I mean the
learning trajectories of the agents with
human participants playing the game for
the first time and they notice that
their agents had the same learning
efficiency the same sample efficiency as
the humans so they would learn the games
in the same amount of time steps but not
only that they had very similar learning
trajectories uh which is very exciting
because because it's to me it's a proof
of concept that active influence like
technology just reproduces the type of
learning trajectories and the type of
like interacting with the world and
learning about the world that we as
humans do when we first interact with a
new environment yeah that's this is
amazing that's fascinating only because
I remember the dqn paper had millions of
was it millions of of episodes until it
converged right and and even then it I
don't think it was well I mean it was
super human performance on on many of
the games but yeah okay so so you're
saying not only does it um you know the
sample efficiency is similar to humans
the the the conversion pattern is is
similar and that's presumably Testament
to the fact that through this
introspective awareness and knowledge of
our PRI um and imbuing those into the
system it it takes a similar trajectory
as as we would so actually actually I
was surprised for that paper they did
not have any core knowledge then they
had a a subsequent paper called um
inductive biases for Theory based
reinforcement learning where they added
core knowledge and then the agent was
even better like it even it matched
humans even more closely but even
without the core knowledge it did a very
good job now uh the reason for that is
that the environment that they took it's
not actually Atari it's a simplified
Atari uh with much less complexity so
you could argue that you don't need you
don't really need core knowledge to
solve that kind of task which human with
with humanik efficiency uh but if you
have core knowledge then of course
you're faster and you're better and so
on I would say as we move to more and
more complex environments core knowledge
would probably play play a bigger role
in so far as we want humanlike sampl uh
humanlike learning efficiency yeah and
of course that really depends on the
goal of what we want as we as we talked
about just before yeah yeah L this has
been absolutely amazing it's been great
thank you so much thank you so much I
really really enjoyed talking with you
and and you gave a brilliant account of
yourself so thank you so much thank you
so much yeah I love it